what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
little baby and little dirk
man of my word before i start you guys
already know don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers and each and every one of
you
help me get to that goal
all right
what's going on what's
what's happening okay i guess it keeps
going
where are they going i want to be
invited
it looks like maybe they're going to a
party
you don't know what it took all right
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so he's saying first point he had
is that who she's hooking up with
outside of him
it's not his business he just minds his
own business
um and he says it doesn't matter he's
like from the trenches so he's just
saying he's like
cooler than other people basically
because he you know comes from like
a place that's like dangerous you're the
first [ __ ] put drums in the city
we rob the [ __ ] with drugs in the city
[ __ ] where you from cause i know that
you with it check on his hands
trust you another [ __ ] more than once
and you gotta be a killer just to hang
with us
okay so he's saying you got to be brave
to hang with us because we'll kill ya
we will i'm not kidding i'm hanging up
run up on the bow ain't no 101 i got the
money so who i'm running from
i got a lawyer
oh dear um
that was a lot i'm gonna just keep going
[ __ ] cry out loud when they get a shot
that [ __ ] don't stand up
yeah you're gonna cry if you get shot i
would that's painful
okay so he's saying like girls will get
naked and put on
his clothes basically um so it makes him
elevate it elevates his level of cool
because if they just got naked for him
that's one thing but now they're putting
on his merch
that's even more she freaked out
no shirt when i'm off okay so she's a
freak but she's acting like she's
you can be a freaky nerd i didn't
realize it was one or the other
time we heard lost bro i know it hurts
we gonna catch em first yeah you run
again on the boy
make her get out of here coming i still
ain't gonna chill out i'm really dead
i'm gonna show him get
wow um
that's a lot of booty in this video a
lot a lot of naked girls but you really
don't know you just achieved i didn't
took off for real now how that feel
bro ain't never gonna change i know
that's real this one out of here
straight to the backfield
so he said he's never gonna change which
is a good message no matter how rich and
famous you get
you should be who you are don't change
for the fame i'm good every night now
i'm happy
how you go where you go i'ma travel for
real how you know okay so he said he's a
trapper
um and i'm not 100 sure what that means
but i think it means
i can't think of one thing other than
like trapping like
animals but i i'm pretty sure it might
mean that maybe he's
cool or that he is from like a hood
area i don't know we're too rich with
the fans we put [ __ ] in the middle my
lifestyle expensive this [ __ ] hot as
hell a bro trying to go so i gave him a
little i gotta go so i know i can't live
you better not [ __ ] [ __ ] get [ __ ]
gotta put on my merch i got your uber i
kept my words
[Music]
wow wow
what's in the bag it's a nice bag
i don't i'm not i like the outfit i'm
just not a fan of like
the bandana on guys
um okay
i think this was a cool music video um
i'm gonna say on a scale of one
two five i'm gonna give it a
three so look slightly above average it
was fun
um i would watch again but
i couldn't understand a lot of the words
so that's why i'm like kind of deducting
some points
but let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree um don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell i'll talk
to you guys next time